So this weekend, Fox News was completely off
the deep end in a hilarious amalgam of calculated
cancel culture complaints and possibly even
drunken hosts again.
Yes, I'm talking about Jeanine Pirro.
So let's take a quick tour through all of
it.
Now, I have to tell you, I expected right
wing media to get really, really nuts when
Donald Trump left.
And there were a lot of different reasons
for that.
Some of them were political.
Some of them were financial.
Some of them were the personal sort of goals
of individuals wanting to maintain proximity
to power in different ways or whatever.
I didn't think it would be this cartoonish.
So first of all, Judge Jeanine Pirro, she's
a former judge and host on Fox News.
She hosted Republican Senator Rand Paul, who
at this point is comically not credible as
an individual.
And Rand Paul asserted without any evidence,
you know, because of Joe Biden and Hunter
Biden's alleged connections to China, if China
nuked the United States, Joe Biden might not
even respond what Joe Biden would do nothing
if the U.S. was nuked.
What are you talking about, Rand?
Yes, that's what he's saying.
Take a look.
Real question.
There has been question also of Hunter Biden's
and the Biden family ties to Chinese business.
And there may be something that they consider
that they have an in with the Biden's that
will cause them not to respond to any kind
of nuclear aggression.
I hope not.
Now, of course, that claim was was made, as
you can probably tell, completely without
any evidence whatsoever.
The idea that Biden would do nothing if China
nuked the United States is so absurd as a
thing for a sitting senator to say that the
discussion we should be having is whether
Rand Paul should or can be expelled from the
Senate rather than whether there's any merit
to what he's saying.
And then a seemingly drunk again, I mean,
this is not the first time this has happened.
An unbalanced Judge Jeanine Pirro talks about
cancer culture but fails to mention her own
network canceled Lou Dobbs the day before.
Take a look.
You are the weak ones.
You are the unfaithful ones.
You don't deserve a job with three months
off.
So an entire segment about they'll never cancel
me and canceling this and canceling that,
shutting down.
The other thing, not a single mention of Lou
Dobbs being canceled by Fox News.
That's really the only prominent Republican
cancelation I can think of recently.
Josh Hawley not getting to do a book with
a private company.
That's not a cancelation.
That's called business, but no mention of
the Lou Dobbs cancelation.
Then on another show on the same Saturday
night, Jesse Waters, who's another host at
Fox News, Bret brings in Dog the Bounty Hunter
for political analysis about a supposed crime
wave being driven by Joe Biden, even though
Biden's done nothing of the sort.
Now, dog is not totally coherent here, but
I have to give dog credit.
He didn't feed into the framing of the segment
as much as I would have expected him to.
And he actually said, let's see what Joe Biden
does.
I hope Joe Biden does well.
You'll hear a lot of very strange noises in
the background, dog wearing sunglasses.
I mean, it's all very weird, but dog doesn't
doesn't jump in full headfirst the way I thought
he was going to.
For more on this dog, the bounty hunter, Duane
Dog Chapman.
All right.
Do you agree with my assessment, those four
things that are driving the crime wave?
And what are we going to do about it?
Well, yes, kind of.
I agree.
I just don't think there's that much gloom
and doom.
But, you know, I'd like to everyone is waiting
to see what President Biden's crime plan is.
We hope that he's solid on crime and not that
he's soft on it.
We want him, of course, to back the blue.
We want officers protected.
We want our civil rights protected.
And, you know, we're going into I'm not I'm
an optimist, so I'm excited about going into
the new, you know, the new realm for America
right now.
I want to see what President Biden has got
for for crime and hoping that the prosecutors
are not all soft on crime.
And let's see what he's got right.
We want Joe Biden to be solid and not soft,
but OK.
I mean, thanks, dog.
I at least he didn't come in and just directly
slander Biden the way Jesse Watters wanted
him to do.
I'm guessing that's not the analysis Jesse
Watters was hoping for.
Jesse Watters also did in an.
Entire segment on the supposed canceling of
conservatives, so Jeanine Pirro did a defiant
segment about cancelation of Jesse Watters,
did a segment about cancelation of conservatives.
Lo and behold, Jesse also didn't mention that
Lou Dobbs just 24 hours earlier was canceled
by Jesse's own network.
That apparently was not an important data
point in the cancelation of conservatives
to make the segment.
Then yesterday morning, Republican Senator
Ron Johnson goes on Maria Bartiromo show and
makes all sorts of wacky speculation about
this impeachment all about.
We now know that.
Forty five Republican senators believe it's
unconstitutional.
Is this another diversionary operations that's
meant to deflect away from potentially what
the speaker knew and when she knew it?
I don't know, but I'm suspicious.
Yeah.
So speculation completely without any evidence
there.
And here's a bonus segment.
This is Ron Johnson referring to this is this
I've never heard this before.
He referred to my birth country of Argentina
as Argentina.
I don't know why I absolutely love this bonus
clip for you from yesterday morning.
A study coming just the day before out of
Argentina.
So, as you can see, a lot of chaos coming
out of Argentina, affecting the United States
right now.
And I will be calling my relatives to figure
out what exactly is happening down there.
I need to know really strange stuff happening
on Fox News.
And Fox News is in this interesting little
place where they are trying to figure out.
How do we what what are we there's almost
like an identity crisis on Fox News, on the
one hand, by acknowledging that Joe Biden
won, we lost a bunch of our audience to Fox,
to a Newsmax.
And on on the other hand, if we go crazier,
right, it's hard to go crazier.
Right.
Without getting into the types of conspiracy
theories that get you sued, like about Dominion,
voting machines, Smartmatic or whatever.
At the same time, if we don't go right, we
might keep losing audience.
It's not an enviable position for me to be
where Fox News is right now, but that's partially
because my morality would never let me work
at Fox News in the first place.
So I'm probably not the right person to be
commenting.
But the next few months are going to be very
interesting to watch the dynamics of right
wing media.
And, you know, there's an excellent, excellent
book.
It's I don't even know if this book is in
print.
Still, I was able to get a copy when I taught
that class that when I taught a college class
about media literacy and other things, I got
a copy of this book called Waves of Rancor.
And is it rancor or rancor?
I never knew how to say that word.
In any case, the book is basically about the
history of right wing media.
And it goes back to talking about, you know,
Father Coplin and how a lot of right wing
radio started with the religious orientation
and all.
It's very, very interesting.
And there are sort of like these main eras
that are of significant change to right wing
media and how the right has used various types
of airwaves and methods of communication for
advancing their agenda.
We may be in a realignment right now, and
the realignment is a combination of things.
It's the rift in the Republican Party between
Trump ism and non Trump ism affecting how
these different media outlets relate to each
other and to the real world, combined with
the actual repercussions that some are experiencing
for violating terms and conditions on a variety
of different platforms.
So we could be I don't know what the next
six months will bring.
I do think part of it will will depend on
whether Donald Trump launches this third party.
And we're going to talk about that a little
bit more later on in the program.